you know something wrong with this cord
right Engineers let the same quarter
last war so food podcast Felipe Esparza
Rodrigo Torres right here yeah man he
just got back from Mexico man Shelly
it's all happy came back with fifteen
pounds heavier man like you know they
eat tacos in every corner she was
telling me
yeah man commit I'll go this is food
everywhere dude in good food too not
just like you know basic Mexican food
all the love and passion to well for the
whole don't know what good food is what
is good food just really rich food not
just a no nobody's I love what I did
like the taco didn't mean you know pain
is a picture of what this good food is
well this good food is
um cochinita pibil who's talked about
that last week okay food okay new food
this the taco just like she's basic
other water otherwise our tacos which is
like a bastard but it's not put on the
Alba so director flips over and under we
can even go farther with that last time
we talked about black man let's just
talk about pinto beans right here refire
or they lawyers a little here in our
later on you're in the bottom but on top
of that it's not even that we can go
with pinto beans frijoles inaudible is a
weird Mexican cooking show it always is
boo don't know what with bacon in there
cut in and then piece is also piece of
the pork and pieces of little tips of
the top shootout erroneous to and those
are just boiled and baked for hours
right there and they're just super super
super good I mean right here in LA you
can get some you know Mexican food which
think is great but I don't think it's
going to be is great is that because
it's just not like put in with the hours
of preparation and love as it is over
there where the source is where they
come from well in my opinion so those of
you that don't know so the street food
is still it's still better than a
regular restaurant inside oh do the
street food dislike do you have like a
samurai right there cuz I would happily
board a say in my Union as what idiot
man like that help you get eat it up do
it just so it's like in it might not be
the most uh healthier stuff on the world
it might be menacing to your health but
for that minute dude [ __ ] is super
super delicious to them you can't
compare it to a minute a minute you
challenge a fast dude I'm telling you I
could take those talking like a seven by
cos and he just mention like a seven
course meal
after that minute and a little talk like
that
and then those tacos ain't as big as the
ones here they're a little bit smaller
come on come with double dark night
Street taco
yeah examines the best yeah I do like I
mean and they're not all double tortilla
up and like over uh listen it keeps
sound like you being cheated like they
don't they don't put the Jumbo tortilla
with it up it's more meat than tortilla
it's a super better dude I mean you
can't compare this so through the bottom
a little bit not too much you have to
double bag it man because I hate I hate
when the taco like melts in your hand or
now you like you know yeah that's the
worst that's one of the two tortillas be
like you know busting up in pieces to
the hook a that I put I need a fat guy
that I used to sell dope with I for
gonna kool-aid they call him kool-aid
now for you to order burrito was to
flour tortillas and I have to also to
floor to tell I never get to take a
tortilla bro one time for this whole
well you know what's funny is like on a
good sandwich like what's the best thing
about a sandwich it's like when you have
a good piece of bread well that's rather
like a freshly big piece of bread can't
mess with improves a sandwich
tremendously I didn't realize this
because you always all you think about
the meat you know you get all this good
pieces like in Turkey or whatever but
when you have that bread sets it off so
maybe a good hand made you know by
somebody's a bolita you know they're you
know and she's just in there right now
y'all you know whatever oh yeah what are
you saying and whatever you're saying
and then that maybe that makes it better
right and then the stuffing for corn
though oh yeah it's wrong and then
stuffing processed like it is here -
what did you become the [ __ ] taco
connoisseur guru Mexico - what Mexico
City twice for time next time since 1998
until now and then like suck I take us
back up or since elevators with you a
sec gotta close the city yeah keep it
what Molly away
what's the literal difference like why
is Mexico a taco and Mexico better than
a taco at like a taco truck in front of
like a club here in LA like what's the
real different cuz a goat is they killer
go right outside I think the guy just
making tacos how you fresh meat
eventually they are the meat right there
that's that's part of it but I think the
guy just making tacos
trouble coast opposed to the goddess
making tacos in Mexico has been doing it
for 30 40 years now I heard the original
guy from King taco he was actually doing
it now now you got employees that like
you know they get pissed off there's
gonna leave well what does it relieve
cuz I want to work there somebody yelled
at them like oh how cool I think their
salsa is phenomenal the red ones ha to
tell essentially have a bum I live on
the west side this is place on Lincoln
and they had these great like shrimp
tacos like if the people can't speak
English I'm on board 100% as the people
that you can understand yet if yet I'm
saying I need to do is can he you know
you know I can tell that he only knows
how to speak whatever I'm ordering I
can't ask for any like changes you know
that's not you there okay I can't be
like no like no this and then he just go
okay you know and they just it comes the
same way every time
yeah I know I know I'm getting something
good oh hell yeah that's what's up right
there it is everybody congregate it's
like a masseuse you know ok speak
English II just got here on a boat from
China hey Josh you know Haiti Emma you
tip now you know I think extra extra
that's a taco equivalent there's a
certain language you have with a
masseuse on you're getting a massage
because you just can't go out there go
happy ending just a what are you talking
about you know should do your cop he'll
kick you out I got kicked out for saying
that before no no I you know what
my good mother a dog I'm not Lionel I
was in one and I knew she's alright she
just beginning stairwell and she kept
pointing to that she's pointing to this
sign that's like a sign on the wall and
it says you know don't ask for sexual
the last for ABS favor say anything out
there and she just did it on her own
like I didn't even ask or anything like
that it was like we I don't know what to
do at the end that's like I don't know
if there was light enough to do I don't
know if there was like some special menu
price that was gonna come out like you
know be like oh do you have to pay me
hundred dollars now so my dad I didn't
know what to do so I was just like thank
you and like here's twenty dollars more
I don't know what to do
yes I unreal in which yeah yeah there's
a lingo to it you know got to be smooth
suppose because I have a list that saves
up half an hour forty bucks right one
hour
eighty bucks then I saw there's other
one where
went to his play they had two hands no
foreheads oh yeah that was human suit
our foreheads world but every besides
myself would take back some service dude
that'll be hilarious if that's what they
said you go where's the other two hands
is yours
not your own ruff hola to pay more hands
at the whole underworld Oh what did you
what in for has be more expensive than
to add oh yeah you're gonna pay TT yeah
you know what I don't like oh I like to
get a manicure and pedicure I like to go
do that so free Hicks and I look busy
and then oh I haven't got it done yet
you know but they look good from here
this is just tight dog slept by those
hands but women notice that right away
don't you know that somebody's feet
music oh oh no sleep anyway of course
all I use on my feet bro yeah my sweet
little later
oh yeah a pop you already married you
cannot worried about that look at those
things through a welding mask but I
don't like sitting in the chair and then
I guess a massage chair
I don't like a massage chair when my
feet are getting massaged because it's
the too much sensation that not massage
chairs rough as hell yeah yeah so I'm
like you take it away from cuz every I
do when I go to the airport I got a
3-hour layover I go get a foot rub
that's what's up I just do it even
though it's $70 you know yeah and I'll
triple it up on the price of it but but
I don't like someone I'm reason why I
bring that up is like if you're getting
a four hand massage I feel like you're
trying to enjoy how it feels on your
feet and if somebody's up here at your
temples I think that's too much right
yeah we're going to start off on the
bottom and work your way up yeah unless
it's like once one hand two hands on
each foot and then they're doing it but
I think I'm yeah liar who has a two foot
who has no legs at at I don't know I
just feel like this is too much it's
over sensation right I always feel like
if I get to if I were to get the two
hands you know something gonna happen
you know they'll get upset one's gonna
choke me now giving a chokehold just
realizing I'm Eric Griffin by the way
you tell by your voice were sold whoo we
have a guest here but
20 minutes in we have all against your
Eric Griffin yeah man for one day at a
time
ha ha ha restless you would pick my one
Latino baby neither I did the pilot and
workaholics on Comedy Central he picked
up four you know what's funny I was at
the went to the Clipper game and the
ticket girl she was like a Latina and
she like saw me among this and she was
like no yeah I recognize me from one day
at a time
it's all really I saw you on Netflix and
I was like oh that's like an audience
there's an audience for that show you
know because it's a Cuban family and you
know there's just like you know that
they keep denying that Latinos watch
television
oh yeah for some reason they think that
the Pinot's don't watch television and
don't want to see Latinos on TV so it's
a weird thing that you don't see you
know just not there's not enough so when
there is something like that at people I
realize how many people in that
community are like oh my god you know so
you become when you let the only latina
in a show it's like when Bruce Lee was
on that show Kato The Green Hornet
Hornet everyone in China let that Bruce
Lee with a star oh yeah yeah two Latinas
on yours oh stop bro they're gonna put
you one more dog like yeah man I'm gonna
control that dog Allah let's talk to the
NBC executives that Colie needs his old
and show collar on on [ __ ] superstore
and funny man like on my home miles my
whole life every job I ever had
like in retail like I want to be in the
front of the store now I was too fat too
big boy house guy warehouse guy Fort Lee
you got that working slip for Smith come
on superstore the day got the show super
story I thought that you know do I get
one of those beige pants and a shirt
that says to person ah man you gonna
pull over you're a mate wait Europe
warehouse guy ah but warehouse wrong and
the one like sort of ethnic guy on the
show they got him in a wheelchair yeah
he could walk I don't know that
yeah the regular dude is like
let's put him in a wheelchair yeah him
through a lot of funny jokes and it
would be faster because in a wheelchair
I tested for that sure I was going out
to be the boss the store manager oh wow
I know didn't get it obviously I think I
read for the wheelchair guy I live yeah
yeah we're for to to patrol really well
I gotta get fired during the get fired
for stealing and wheelchair guy it was
so I thought that year that was the
funniest script I read that was funny
here you know that point one was still
on yes I was so you know we were right
about it season three yeah sucks it
sucks to be like up for something like
imagine if you were like you were number
two to be Sheldon on Big Bang Theory
like if you were the number two guy and
you didn't get it like every time you
watch that show you see the money that
you didn't make you're like Brian
Dunkleman from American Idol or John
Koeppen era from Drew Carey Show oh wow
yeah chocolate burner head on shoujo
Kerry spin-off of that show too weak to
carry short junker but never show that
canceled oh god a year less than a year
that's the bottom back of the guest but
I want to open it because the headline
is that it rarely happened they switched
it on me player
he switched the tag I started out with
him for what was some of the people that
I marry grin for knows I'm his friend
like Sherri Shepherd JT I was into a
club called Wow DOS whereas I'm Waldo's
on Hollywood Boulevard it was called
about Hollywood on Hollywood and
Highland it's been a blonde lady her
name was dawn she had curly long oh yeah
Rio key to on Fridays yes I said a
comedy night we know her um her husband
I think she's never got his name but
they go with go to my show and oh Paso
yeah it was like I remember when I was
like it was like 2003 is when I really
was like okay I want to do this and like
in LA it was anybody in LA starting to
do comedy I'm always like good luck get
out of my face come tell you the guy
your ex I want to talk to you about it
but I remember like the only play
you can really go to get a good audience
and even get paid would be like though
all the Latino show yeah
those only places to be like they give
fifty dollars where the Filipino shows
to neither drunk yeah yeah yeah yes
that's the only place you know you can
you have like a real like lively crowd
it would be if some weird bar or
something like that you know I remember
I got my first TV credit the payaso
comedy slam for a Darren Carter
you guys know Darren Carter Carter
Sardar he called me one day was like yo
can you come with me to this gig he only
wanted me to come so he can be in the
carpool lane only to the body yeah
so you know at the time I just thought
you know I went that Alex Reymundo was
on the show and it was like a place that
he said that you know somebody had
gotten shot what's that dude that works
with wood fluffy Marteen Marteen was
running the show and it was at a place
that somebody gotten shot oh yeah that
was uh that way out and yeah yeah that
was the ocean ocean it was a it was like
Andrews on a ride out that night he got
murdered it was initiated name it was
called it was called something else of
the bumble rumor of that it was like a
weird little location Babu room became
ocean yeah but I lost a Leffingwell or
so I just happened they say they put me
up on the show and Alex window was after
me so therefore he was watching and then
he's like young man about to do this
show and then likely hit me up the next
week and then the next thing you know
that was my first TV credit 2006 and
that's how you got that yeah that's just
as a random thing going to and I'm
saying going to some like place where
like who be there no one's gonna be here
to what you know I'm saying like this is
the nothing's going to happen from this
but I realized in LA yes it could happen
anywhere whose day night yes some random
night and so I did I did that and I got
on that and then like it was until like
2008 that I got on like live at Gotham
and then from there and then in 2010 9
10 is when I auditioned for workaholics
and then that's that's when I got that
that's bitchin dude yeah she was also
accomplished with all borders with
Russell Peters oh I'm never on the same
show I hated at you oh my god they chose
my clothes you know what okay were doing
war
why I hate it I hate it because we
filmed 10 episodes in a one-night same
crowd a name shirt button I was making
the crowd like you know what it's just
cheap you know what I'm saying it was
just cheap making the crowd like move
around and then they only had to they
had one crowd and maybe like half of a
crowd outside so they were like at some
point they were like well if you want to
leave you can leave and it was that was
the word I hated that so much because I
just felt like we're set up for failure
yeah and you know we had a unisex green
changing room where all the women
comedians and the and the guy comedians
share the stage of dressing room so the
female comedian there was only like four
of them they were to make their own
little curtains from us the same the
same room slash idea audio got a - yes
one of those are the worst kind of oh I
hate those are not real they want to be
stars - everybody's got a head shot for
some reason this fall and when the
director comes by real real what I have
to do my DVD fell out of my pocket you
know it's just the worst it's weird like
I feel bad you know use when you're like
a young comic or just new in this
business you see like Oh ma'am I should
get that [ __ ] I've ever seen like young
comics I don't know how they were and
they had to like a PR person and their
manager you know - people the three of
them are all known there's what I had to
go like well I'll have that yeah
so I need a man the grass is always
greener on the other side I even more so
than that I remember doing in like 2004
I did the Seattle comedy competition and
at the time it was like that was like a
big deal doing Seattle doing San
Francisco remember those days so I
remember did Seattle and I hated it I
hated every moment of it like contests
are the worst okay it's just
and but only thing it trains you for is
auditioning doing like a five minute
showcase it trains you to be like boom
boom boom but it was just a worst
experience and then after that I
remember the guy John Fox I see him at a
bar he's doing some stuff and he's like
Eric I want you to come to San Francisco
and I remember saying no I was like no
I'm not going because it's like I'm not
gonna put myself through that but before
they
two or three years before that that was
the thing I was like I got a kid in in
San Francisco Comedy Competition you
know now and then after you do some
stuff you start to go anis that's not as
important as I thought it was the same
thing with some of these TV credit I
know like young comic I'm like they
drove to like March and Rizzo Johnnie
rocky Channel right Jose Chavez Flaco
and a bunch of comedians they got a car
they drove to Seattle for that for that
mmm CNBC toader than everybody oh my god
man yeah they always mention people who
could also leave out of it so while we
are the white guilt auditions yes
how is true like what a waste right yeah
because always people people those guys
there was people not Latino ones there
was no leg people with breath those like
they always die throughout names of
people who were on it but I wanna get
[ __ ] from Italy you know our air ecology
was one of the guys yeah but I'm hitting
a shape of a dog you gotta don't think
yeah he did his own thing
well I mean it's like it's weird I mean
I think it's weird for you know for me I
you know I had this multi-ethnic look so
it just depends on who I'm with so
people gonna see us together they're
gonna be like who's that Porto Rican guy
no but if I'm with my black friends you
know some of my family they're gonna be
like oh look it's Drake's father you
know I mean so it just depends on where
you are here's the Karma casino [ __ ] Rue
de Varenne oh I used to look he was
another guy that he'd be the only one
that would pay yeah if you wanted to get
a good spot at a good show you would do
a Rudy show but like for me it's like I
realize when you go to diversity things
it's become diversity for comedy it's
just really just like it's black first
and then everything else but
unfortunately it's like you know white
kids are buying
rap albums you know they say 7 out of 10
rap albums are bought by white kids
right because they're trying to love
they love the culture they look at
basketball they want to be black it's
that you know once why kids start
wanting to be Latino then it's just like
it's gonna change go change the lezzy
please that's not the case that's that's
why it's like it's hot I think that's
the thing that is harder for Latinos to
break through because it has to be for
Latinos you know if it's not for Latinos
and they're like well I don't know if I
relate to this like you're not on yeah
like nobody's going around just and I
can't walk right now right but the other
thing is Latinos are new to Phil show
business I mean brothers been around
since the inception but not forever bro
but dude been in the may not include
yeah not included just dizzy or there's
out there you go some see but I mean but
that's like before that was before black
people were on TV yeah very separate bed
like it was okay to have Desi Arnaz on
that show like be Latino but it's
tougher now then that marries like it
work already back then there was a
morality award back there they were not
ready back then but but they feel like
they're more scared now that they were
wrong but hit but the thing is he had he
had to do it himself
yeah if he knows can learn anything from
desi Arnaz's like he didn't he did it
himself he invented the memory yeah he's
a yeah he vented all that he had to do
it all himself goes back to what he was
saying earlier they think Allah Tino's
just watched channel 52 and 34 no no no
no no the problem is a lot of Latinos do
watch channel 52 and that's the problem
that what I'm saying is like that's a
huge market I'm a broad way to like you
ever go to those like Latino commercial
auditions
I've gone I gotta wanted and I could
steal vanish only Spanish on I can feel
the hate because I don't speak Spanish
because I'm not you know to me and I go
in and then they see me in and I start
talking hey everybody what's going on
how you doing and it's like not taking
up with Julian okay when they put a
Latino on prime-time it's always one
with an accent it's from like Mexico or
Spain and I mean but then you hear them
in the interview in the exactly why this
guy you've ever met how long exactly
because otherwise they're really why
that's still a thing it's like it's so
weird
I tell you for comedy is like that but
if it's like a procedural cop show it
don't matter
right you know it can be but here that
guy's gonna be good-looking Oh totally
[ __ ] Rico suave guy I got ya guy that
was a big hit on that's a soap operas
person yeah dude I mean good Gerardo and
all that [ __ ] that happened after but
but there is a huge I mean there's like
there's people making so much money in
the Latino market but I don't know what
this need is to cross over though that's
something you have to ask too so yeah
it's like you're talking about channel
52 yeah it's a hit there's like millions
of people watch that channel
right
like the Latinos are tuning into what
they want to watch but there but you
know when you get into the business you
go I want I want like as if being on the
on the white networks is somehow
legitimizing yeah it's not I know it
doesn't matter like growing up a lot of
comments when I first started they all
wear a cross over they will do a show
like like to see Wilbur said I don't do
[ __ ] show yeah I don't do [ __ ] show
kind of OB nurse shows as you can say
that'll do beater show but now you can't
sell out it can't sell you can download
a hundred 100 people room me only what
on the other hand I just talked to my
gun that's you know what these people
love me they could come to my shows you
know building a little audience oh by
the way I sold our seven show that the
Irvine improv last year yeah man
if everybody's asking and Elvis parts at
Irvine with a one spot that la Latino
comedian couldn't get booked because no
not too many Latinos go to Irvine but a
man they forgot that got sold out color
mercy I used to sell out Paulo Francisco
used to sell out
you bet you sell out you and your
Philippe responds back your best friend
Jeff Garcia did it redone but I've never
he never showed up just so that your
best friend knows he never sold out now
he did he was like you I had to give
come on you gotta give Jeff credit there
was a time when like the world they
never had to leave California yeah they
would you he would do Ontario right if
you did hear that Ontario
Irvine Brea a nice house he did those
for comedy clubs every single year never
would have to go occasionally I mean he
gonna go to Texas but for the most part
he stayed right here in California and I
was like I was making give me new some
money that I'd have to go would you
thank you for while I bring this up why
do I break this up otherwise you're I
think subconsciously I knew is you talk
about walls but you make this for fifty
thousand dollars of cartoons why would
you want to go into it yeah well that's
the whole day now right because you got
a love comedy I love it and now he can't
even sell a room packed with 605 Lord
unless DJ Kue [ __ ] from Orissa no
seizure couch the [ __ ] gorilla
everybody
and Ernie G come on that's big booty
Latino comedy bro
that guy you know the balloon you do
like motivational speaking or something
like that now he's trying to call a
comedy but that's what he's doing how
our me broke your not denied parole or
DG and cows they're doing the same exact
thing
dog they going on a tour yeah but that
dudes another one that so they're
getting into National Council of life
and taking their money with I don't know
he what he need to get called out on a
bush always did something I know
something I always wanted doesn't
doesn't it always feel like there can
only be one great Latino comic at a time
not anymore
I think people used to think that way
because there was only one dude yeah I
want to know I want that way but now I
don't
that's you know glad he said because you
know it is whose turn is I think it's
more tunnel version of its moral animal
it in Florence more like God you know
it's like um when I was a Last Comic
Standing and little rel was sitting down
and other black cotton was sitting here
another black comment was sitting here
and Alonzo Pat Alonzo Bodden passed by
the for everybody know they only gonna
pick one of you guys he goes doesn't
even we have there's too many John
Rhodes here you know what get honored
one guy's gonna go yeah but we don't
have a glass top when I was like coming
Stanley and I thought cristela long
stood on the shore I never know sure
dishes okay man
that means she definitely follow coming
the record on me I gotta go hey you won
yeah yeah I did the next day my son mom
Papa child support of course of course
were so fool so what did you start doing
undercover yeah um I was in LA I I grew
up I was born and raised in LA I started
you know when I it was in 2003 that I
was like okay I really want to do this
and I started going to all the open mics
I went to
member Marvin marries I don't know if
you ever even did that one but I did
like I did a bunch of like open mics and
then I started going down to the Queen
Mary
they had that Koopa comedy club down on
there laughs is hope on the Queen Mary
then from there I started going to the
remember how the ice house had those
shows on the weekend in the Annex they
had three shows on Friday three shows on
Saturday I started doing no shows so I
did that for like a year and then after
I got in into haha you know so I started
going to the haha and and Terry loved me
you know it means he's crazy but I love
her so she got mad at me because I got
banned from that Club a good reason for
chasing the devil around anyways enjoy I
solely plus her ball every time I see
her and I said um what's up Bob cherry
matter who you give um Avery Griffin a
development deal to host every weekend
for six are you making fun of my club
and making fun of our club no no making
funny a clever boy one of Eric Griffith
bachelor a shitty comedy between you
between you really Barcena and Jeff
Garcia it was just a nightmare
okay so nightmare hahaha
non-stop [ __ ] talking are so I totally
[ __ ] him establish after him the
Tommy turn laughter's so we went so then
from there as I was doing the haha I got
in at the Comedy Store
so I started I got a showcase there but
then I started doing the belly room
there then after that I got in at the
Laugh Factory and then you know at while
this was all that was happening it was
when I got on like lava Gotham that I
got on workaholics and then you know
you're Here I am
so you know now I'm on this new show I'm
dying up here which premieres this
Sunday on Showtime
and my first hour special comes out July
7th what the ugly truth on Showtime so
hell yeah I'm a Showtime boy now for
sure when he was gonna get him a purple
shirt it looked good I look good in
purple
hater man but I didn't like what they
made me wear about that day
I know oh my god do I leave a dress like
that I were still rest I t-shirt man I
came in there like hi-ho silver under
the concrete whatever Lone Ranger they
thought the UH I get particular asses on
yeah man you know man oh my god 44 you
can learn from a gangster to our old
Mexican grandpa in like a second
now we have trouble with it what just
happened I hug
hey bro and it usually gonna get my
glasses I'm gonna read I can't even read
the menus at the Mexican restaurant
today I was gonna rent stuff to have
photos bad for the shop man can't you
just realize how old we are we all get
yeah that was great
this will hey I'm still your little
already lagging Showtime
my man so send me on Showtime June 4th
is called him dying appear it's about
comedy in the 70s you know so I got a
nice afro in this you know so it's great
ari Graynor
Melissa Leo like Adam E Award winner
she's great in it she's playing like the
sort of Mitzi character it's loosely
based on the book produced by Jim Carrey
and you carry like you know here's a lot
of it's about his own personal stories
too that he you know put on these comics
that are in the show I mean it's it's
it's a fantastic cast I'm proud of the
work we did so I hope people like it and
starts June 4th I don't know when this
is coming out but June is already Oh
perfect
so June 4th this Sunday then Sunday
10:00 10:00 p.m. on Showtime and then
look out for my special July 7th
yeah man are you paid Tyree on that show
no no I'm sure you look like brother
solid David Tyree they would tell you
real LF a man is dumb Elmas it's a
regret for playing um David Tyree that's
little just like you when you were young
guys need to know why fedora yeah it's
like they you know I was like you know
because I'm you know because I'm so
mixed it's like if you if you need to
like play up whatever part of the tool
is the afro you know
I mean I was I all hoping no shut the
movie like in the 90s but then I could
play Chewie stand outside but the
overall chewy [ __ ] door man where's
our food
Showtime percent I'm dying up here a new
drama series that explores the struggles
of making it bigger the 1970s la comedy
scene every night a group of young and
up-and-coming comedian wait their turn
to perform at Goldie's the hottest
tandem club in Hollywood but they're but
first I'll have to win over the club
owner Goldie who rules the Sunset Strip
with an iron fist for them stand up it's
a drug and they're willing to sacrifice
everything to get their fix they braved
the pain of sharing their innermost
thoughts and darkest secrets hoping that
someone anyone will laugh at goalie's
they have fun new rivals but they also
found a family when one of them makes it
they'll make it and when they all fail
they fail they fell together but if
Johnny Carson's couch is the Holy Grail
do they wait for the goal to say you're
ready or fly blind and possibly miss out
on their shot at stardom
don't miss I'm dying up here executive
produced by Jim Carrey premieres Sunday
June 4th at 10:00 p.m.
I've been reading the book I stole him
from right here that's a while outside
here I've been borrowing it it's when I
when I read it I'll bring it all back
man I was talk back there bro really
tough because um didn't they pay the
comedian though before the strike on yes
before the strike and like were they
just to the comic store pay now any pay
the regular pitching bug though yeah
still 15 bucks and then you get and they
split the door in the main room yeah I
can do that rule 10 when a cat they
split the door with the count in the
main room you get it's a nice chunk when
you're in to go get a good chunk though
yes you're in town I think I think if I
think the Laugh Factory pays the best
you know but they don't split but they
pay of those a per spot you know if you
go do Long Beach you know you do Long
Beach and even the regulars we can't
spot that they pay the most
but they know the main room in the comic
store that pays the most out of all of
them because if you're in the main room
like I say they go split the door with
the comics half the door goes to the
comics
but when you're in the city and in the
improv I don't have any been going to
the improv like okay you go to the
improv in now it's like one show you get
eight dollars Wow another she'll be
twenty five dollars then another she'll
be fifty dollars and another she'll be
twenty one dollars I get so weird I
don't know how they're deciding what
they pay they said I produces it or
whatever yeah I add again they still
take taxes away from those checks too
but I check a dollar change like sixty
it's a shame everybody's little piece of
the pie huh I think in a Comedy Store
I'm getting one check I'm working there
it was like a hundred sixty five bucks I
but I think this would be the time for
you to come back there because like it's
different now yeah it's going through a
Renaissance man it's like it's hot it's
like you know they talk about they got
sold-out shows on the weekends all the
time now the other clubs are struggling
they're struggling to keep up with what
they're doing because it's because all
the comics go there now and like the big
comics you know when Chappelle's in town
he goes to the comedy store when Chris
Rock was working on his stuff for the
Oscars he goes in the comic store Joe
Rogan's back there now you know bill
Birds always there when Louie pops into
town when he pops everywhere
but like you see all those guys
collectively at the Comedy Store so it's
a lot it's a great time to be in there
right now pumping on yeah
bump it bro people still getting bumped
you know not as much into comedy stories
you would think it still happens but and
the people are pretty respectful they'll
do like 10 minutes 40 minutes but
sometimes somebody that hasn't doesn't
go through all the time comes in like
the other night I brought up Kevin Hart
you know he just came in and he did like
an hour and it's just you know what he's
supposed to do that he that's the first
comic in like 10 years to be on the
Forbes list ahead of Seinfeld mm-hmm you
know that's why this is enormous yeah
yeah so he's had a great year
hahaha yeah he's number one that year
he's number one he was number one last
year this year so he was you know of
comedic whatever that Forbes list that's
like he made 110 million that year yeah
because I saw you know cooking all the
money he makes off Seinfeld every year
so for the first time somebody like
surpassed that it's like damn
it's good I like when comics are doing
stuff I like to see comics on TV I like
to see them in movies and shows because
it's like then we go okay well then they
they're going oh these people can do it
because it sucks when you it sucks when
somebody gets a chance and they just
like you know because any they lump us
all together like you know it's like oh
that's that sucked so that means all
comics sucks get them out of here you
know we're not hiring no more commas you
ever again from a little dancer this
decade although my goal you know what my
dream I knew your comic that East Coast
League when I was there like what every
time you bring to your comments to the
comic super no pass oh man they give
away tickets and manage people still
don't show up you don't think I don't
understand I like going to New York
because if you want to do a lot of
comedy because you know I'm here in LA
if we get through if you got to set to
the night you're like oh I did it you
getting six seven set to the night over
in New York if you're in now if you in
if you're in but that's what they should
be way funnier you know what I mean yeah
I know like they brag about our brother
pair hundred dollars a check I did nine
shows yesterday yeah but I saw your
headline they don't give it away tickets
you did all the radio you did TV no one
showed up bro well that but what I do
this hard to get an audience man it's
like one thing I'll say for like I think
that the people that are a specific
ethnicity you know it's like II think
they're finding their audience a lot
easier if you can find whatever your
audience is and you because it's like it
that that suckers hard man you take it
from me I mean you know it's like I
they're workaholics fans that sometimes
comes to the show but like they don't
know like comedy fans or not those
people because they're like you know
it's young they don't got money they're
in college you know they're not coming
to they don't even understand how to go
out and then and then people that are
like 30 and up proper comedy crowds
they're not watching workaholics and
then they're there announced me is the
guy from workaholics and people like oh
well what kind of what is he going to do
what kind of calm you know so that's why
I'm glad to be on this new show that
have a special cone out because now
people can see me in a whole different
light they don't even know I'm a comic
we actually do yeah it's hard to like
but then you hear like you know there's
somebody that's got an itch that they're
out there selling out [ __ ] you know it's
like people say you must be selling out
too right because you use on that show
it's like no it doesn't work like that
it worked it was not worth I say you
know so it's like you know you have to
just find you yet to find it and it
speak to him you know you did stand-up
comedy he's funny
yeah it's that a lot yes man it comes to
me to go or they come to me and go oh
man I thought you were gonna do that
thing you do on the show
they don't know they don't get it and
then and that's why then they're the
clubs are hiring these goddamn YouTube
people you know after I was in Alabama
and this I only went over to Wayne's
that's not gonna be 100 still and I
smell the some of the YouTube dirt I run
at any time art Wayne's he was up at
11:30 with a little less horseshoes just
like a little donkey not a different guy
this guy wasn't some guy cowboy
something to brother were yesterday boy
Wayne some he have some video about
where he's like he's playing like
somebody's mom or something you know and
he and he was on stage the place was
jam-packed they had him doing the 7
o'clock show when I was doing like the
night show you know and the place is
jam-packed just - he liked my crowd is
outside 45 minutes he's still on stage
doing meet and greet others kind of
stuff green room was packed with his
people and I'm like what the [ __ ]
going on studying in his fault he didn't
go through the process how does he know
how you treat other people how does he
know he has no respect for stand-up
comedy at all and the clubs don't care
cuz they hire him the owner the owner
wasn't saying call me Joel called me a
lot in the green room because this guy
they asked him the night before they say
hey can you not you rant you know
there's another show and you're taking
two you take he did it he was sewing he
got assaulted by that and stayed even
longer on doing who and a half that was
yeah yeah yeah and so then they go his
owner calls me Harry I'm so sorry I go
hey dude stop it's cool I get it but you
know you hired him this is what you get
you know this is what happens and then
that's all they care about but there's
no love for like I feel like this it's
like I get
it's a business and you gotta make money
but I feel like sometimes there's no
respect for comedy anymore at the level
that they're presenting it you know the
club's themselves don't have any respect
for the process like this this is that
this young kid learn or less that's
groom people they don't even do that
anymore they're just like alright who's
got a million hits on YouTube who we can
come in here and pretend like they do
stand-up comedy
let's bring them in show me the money
play yeah and then but then what is that
going to do for our business what's
gonna do for our industry man and to
wait and see man I was act like it was
he was just a lot of times too they
don't do the thing that people want to
see but he just was like I didn't even
watch I wouldn't do green room door
would open he would just be up there
like you know well you know that come on
who is it - yeah we just look like Sarah
we in a crowd was just like ah you know
they go crazy yeah they just wanted to
take pictures and do other stuff I mean
I get it if you if something goes viral
and people like it it doesn't look I'm
not hating on social media stars it is
what it is it's not the same business
too many comics are always complaining
about you know social with you people -
tickets like know that that's a whole
different animal you know if you want to
do that go do that
you know but if not there you're not
certain so many comics are so entitled
yeah you know I mean like we like we
deserve something you know you know it's
like just because you tell jokes so many
people want to hear them true so true
that you know so it just turns into like
this you know it's like to me it's the
difference between baseball and softball
it looks the same but it's not the same
you know and that's the difference
between like that kind of online
charming comedy social media communist
but it's charming kids you know it's
good-looking people for like a short
amount of time and the girls and fans
out there who like oh I love this you
know and then so they go how come out
it's a money grab like how can I make
some money and get to my fans well they
do it at a comedy club you know and then
they just push it out to
that I've been building a knack for 10
years you know and then they got famous
by saying when women is late for dinner
nearly acted all out yeah it's crazy
what they do out there but but this was
not anything new this is like when
actors become calm comedians yeah you
know I mean they just go can they go or
you can make how much money because
people come I remember when Mike
McDonald first started doing comedy you
know from MADtv [ __ ] tall dude he
was when he first started doing it and
they asked me it was at the Irvine
improv and when the old or run improv
and he asked me he said hey can you come
and do the show with him and I remember
I went you know the place was jam-packed
and he would not do Stewart oh and they
wanted to see it and people are
screaming down you know they're
screaming at him and he just wouldn't do
it so he did a little bit of it and then
like he had his notebook he was going
through his stories he was just trying
to get you know lose jam-packed I'm
[ __ ] comic so I'm in there like all
my yet you know whatever I love about
you know I remember this woman comes up
to me she's like oh my god you were so
much you know better it should give me
it's just I said to her I said thank you
very much but if my name was right here
if it said Eric Griffin would you'll
come you know probably not so thank you
for this compliment but move the hell
along or they tell you you should be
little ahead oh yeah I did the comments
should even get happy when I tell them
that anymore
like if somebody was all nonsense if
they tell you that in front of the
headliner you should even get happy yeah
yeah you should you look at the record
well he brought me so yeah you know
Eddie yeah yeah go ahead
yeah you didn't come for me but I like
you came because of what this person has
accomplished yeah so whether he was
funny like I remember I was I did a show
with Damon Wayans and he was cashing it
in man he was like looking on his phone
with new jokes you know that was an open
mic for him was a weekend at the Irvine
improv sold-out Wow
you know cuz he was just like let me
look on these things so of course
somebody would come up to you and be
like oh my god I thought you were so
much better and I was like okay whatever
like what does that mean cuz I cuz I'm
trying to be better I'm not you know
yeah you being real about me I'm coming
up here in like you know did you know I
did my job being working you know but
you didn't come for me
sitting there with your chest puffed up
yeah yeah yeah I could work there 500
people to come in here so we'll talk
right there no it's like that you that's
part of it now if you want to talk about
you have a responsibility as a headliner
to put on the best show possible I agree
with that I think if people come to the
show you know they want you to like
perform do you do your thing but you
know we get you know you get so famous
people sometimes people get lazy they
just get lazy yeah yeah man I know I go
up there with notes and all those great
flair to them buy a house and get that
far grab it my money I've been wallet $5
popped out fill it up from beneath
release Navidad you have our family's
from Belize and always double your fun
enjoyable easily make a family from
Honduras you know that's why I was weird
look cuz I don't know what I am every
time I say Russell Peters he's like you
ain't black man ha ha ha whatever it's
like we did if a guy would a dick can
identify as a woman then I can identify
with whatever [ __ ] race I want no oh
yeah I'm like I'm non-binary Rachel but
yeah but non-binary biracial whatever
and this is what I want to be a so I
want to be called [ __ ] you know
I mean not he not she not they you know
so if people can do that then I can just
associate with whatever you know this is
great look for like you know for for TV
because people I could be whatever you
need the only place it wouldn't be good
would be prison because like I wouldn't
know what gang to join you know no
that's the issue
yeah whoever they're whoever's winning
you know the system Jailhouse Rock if
the Latinos and winning all those I'm
like one of their make me a trustee yeah
what you want playa so what does it mean
to make it as a comedian these days in
the 70s 80s willows are tonight shows
that you made it but then the internet
everyone comedy making an online I
remember being on Letterman with a big
day we're doing a big thing for a
comedian right now
I thought was what's up into a yoku me
to be shooting for besides being funny
um god that's such a great course there
are so many avenues now I think that I
guess I guess the I guess the big thing
now is luck I'm half of it is luck I
mean it would be like if you got some
viral video I mean that's bigger than
anything I mean look what happened with
Steve Trevino you know like whatever to
him he got well I bring stuff up with
this [ __ ] too he got he put a
video from his special and then it went
viral
he had like a section of his oh that's
right and it was about him his wife dad
with a smile of flicks it was super
viral and then that was he put it out
ordeals or he put it out we put it out
on this like I'm just like Facebook or
and it was like YouTube Twitter a just
it just went viral and so then therefore
people are like oh I want to go see more
of this guy I'm glad he did it that way
because that's that bit and could be
easily taken by these um meme stars you
know these social or another yeah
there's that way and it's all his and he
gets credit for America's I don't but I
think in this climate
what you need is consistency keep doing
visibility content have to continue to
come out so like first is I've been on a
show for seven seasons but there's still
people out there that don't know who I
am don't even know I do comedy so like
right now it's like that's what I'm
doing a bunch of things I'm doing a
bunch of podcast so I got my special
coming out and then I just did Corden
you know and it's like so I got to do
more things like that and just stay
consistent and then then hopefully it
catches on people are like oh I like the
sky you know oh I owe that after guy
from the Philly and then they just you
know that's true because even though
like I sold out seven shoulder but an
improv the next day well I'm walking
around oh 14 shows in a row by the way
also lovely that step to the first time
I walk down the street in a gig I
haven't seen as long as I have three pay
should used to do it comedy yeah you
know what's funny in LA like you got to
be careful in LA because you know you
don't know why people know you
so remember this girl walked up and she
goes oh my god I know you and I said I
was like I didn't want to be like well
you know I'm oli
you know I don't want to be like that
and I'm so glad because she goes up we
go to that you go to that same
restaurant I go to in Santa Monica I saw
you there a couple times and I'm like
okay that's how people it is in LA you
know you don't know you don't know why
people know you where you you know but
that's how people are anyway they want
to like take away your shine anyway
that's just how he knew you still doing
comedy human nature maybe he pretty
[ __ ] food better know Brooks healthy
no social media no smart phone no
nothing huh yeah but if you don't have
whatever happen to you if you don't
behave there nephews that know what's up
don't you ever wonder about what
happened to certain comics like just
think of the comics we knew we known
each other now since like like 2004 five
take thinking back to like you ever
think about some guys that go where's
that guy yeah man I always feel like you
know the guy had said once yeah yeah
even guys are but you know but here's a
problem there's a little excited I just
thinking that right now if there's a
level of comics that like you get to a
cap and they're in this middle ground
and they're making a living I make it a
living that comedy is not hard that's
not the hard part the hard part is name
recognition the hard part is you know
get into that upper echelon oh hell yeah
the elite yeah that's the hard part but
there's a lot of people who can make it
live and do a comedy okay
and when I go to certain comedy clubs
and if I see I do with a cowboy hat like
the picture you know the pictures on the
wall that's I know what kind of comedy
club I'm at if I see a puppet or a
cowboy hat and I'm like oh man what a
[ __ ] am I gonna duel the hair right
you're the punched in Atlanta so we
stare at the photos so we're talking
about all these guys we're talking about
they're in that middle ground and they
just kind of fade away I remember Dan
Smith we saw him a possum emboss yeah
he's in Boston now no but he's got like
he's writing he's got a family like but
I remember when like comedy was his
thing yeah what it was cooking yeah
there's a good on tour with George Lopez
cracking for him I'm saying with this
broken USO tours there's people like
that there you go where are they now you
know
and it's like people don't character
like why didn't even know who that guy
was anyway yeah where are they now that
never make it that's like it's like the
net people that never like and they're
on the cusp of getting something bigger
the cuspid is not what I fly this is so
hard this is hard do you think like
maybe some people don't feel like they
were doing a little um but they feel
that they made it to this door you know
they stood around and they see the be
friends up there making it I still like
sooner or later so a little bone you
know but I better stick around and I
done that right I took around that this
long I was struggling you know but I
just don't know I well struck me because
you know when you have drugs to use and
you pay your register I'm doing alright
yeah if you just I might have you can
hire your rent and have an addiction you
doing good
that's why so I mean that's like
actually a sign of success you can still
pay a rent and afford your addiction you
know you doing alright he's doing too
bad
naina less I would like some other guy
that were so talented when you're coming
up but you said where the hell are they
now god I don't man you saw people right
I did see I had two stages of doing it
when I was really young
are you first started right I first
started I went to like a comedy class
and I went to like open mics every eight
weeks you know what you were at it that
was like 92 log like that
I got 94 that's when I was I was 98 yeah
it was like nine that was like I wasn't
even but I wasn't even do hang around
with JT yeah I wasn't even doing that
stuff at that point I just was like that
he just became my friend working just
yeah I had a regular job I wasn't even I
wasn't even doing I didn't really I
didn't make comedy my focus until 2003
but in the early parts I remember doing
open mics with Jim Gaffigan really yeah
I really was doing that long yeah I
remember I remember she told me he was
young I remember seeing Jamie Kennedy I
remember when Jamie Kenny was sleeping
on people's couches and a car yeah I
remember you know who lunch there's just
a lot of those type of natural edge
there's a lot of those type of people
they had to show at this coffee shop in
Venice I forgot to name it a place but
it'll cause though cause in yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah something the cows
then it's a Marina del Rey
oh I've been there's a different one
that's a different oh that's a different
one but uh you know I just remember
seeing after but but but at the time I
had no tutelage I didn't know what I was
supposed to do I would go to over an
open mic you know after work and be a
dis open mic and it's just being like
what the hell is this I saw these people
six weeks ago they're doing the same
[ __ ] they haven't made it and then you
had to go to like remember um remember
uh out in the valley the Cabaret oh my
god la cabaret on Balboa and yeah so
that was I mean you did yeah you had to
pay you had abayas drink to perform so
late so at that time I'm like I'm tired
I'm gonna work eight to five and then I
had to drive out to the bali to do it to
pay to do a set in front of some hacky
ass comics and like you know it's like
yeah I don't know what you know it just
was like this is what I want they got
any for one I didn't think I could do it
I didn't really think I could make it
that's it was just a pipe dream and
that's what's wrong with most people
they don't think they can really do it
they they think the task is too daunting
you know like how am I gonna get like
these people and it's like you can't
think like that it's like the moment
when I really focused in on it and then
I just it just became like like a
mission and then you know it happened
yeah man yeah man
nothing's up though man that's for real
though man a lot of [ __ ] you
know get caught in that cloud do comedy
is more so known with the Horta or cut
throat um I think it's more I I don't
think that's the right words competitive
is a better work I don't think it's cut
so I think it's competitive and I think
that it's also cliquish so if you have a
clique then you get your support yeah
yeah your support because you're gonna
help your clique I learned when I got
back it was new clique it was like man I
don't even at the time coming up I was
such a solo I just tried to like I knew
I had to cultivate relationships so I
had like that group of people that would
be at the Queen Mary so if you were at
like if you were someone that regularly
went to the Queen Mary then you know you
would be that was the clique you know I
mean
like I remember that's where I met ty
Rivera you know that's what I meant like
so many people there that are you know
and then then we went to the haha
there was the ha ha click you know wrong
you know or you know all the people that
would be there you would be there you
have Garcia you know all Gabriel Gabriel
would come until he blew up and he was
like he only came for special you know
it was just like that's just what it was
it was like whatever club you were at
whatever open mic you would go to that
kind of became your little extended
family and then you you know then you
try to like break away but like you know
even with your your closest friends
there's a certain level of like
competition you want to have that's how
you push each other it's like if I had a
good if my good friend books a movie
that I'm like ah all right but I'm not
sad I'm still happy for them right it's
gonna get pissed a lot of pissed about
it that those kind of people they don't
make it they just don't make it come on
bro
nobody gives a [ __ ] if you're mad either
do right that's another turn crazy armor
my friend cuz we know you know Jeff my
or you know a good buddy Jeff um he uh
he's Jeff Jeanette now by the way at our
petition that he I remember he I was at
this audition for a movie and the lady
comes to me and she says oh she walks up
to me in the line she's like it was open
call she's like I don't know I think
you're too old for this
I don't think this is right for you but
she said I audition you anyway I read
this and I was like oh [ __ ] this is
perfect for chess I called him I said
dude you gotta get down here right now
do this audition he booked a movie you
know and I was just like at that time I
was like that's how you that's what
you're supposed to have for real dude
but I learned all the funniest movie -
man I learned that my hope my best
friend's dead yes yeah yeah you remember
a hilarya brother who had a [ __ ] it it's
funny I stood in the movie this guy
catches this girl hair is on fire and I
got to put it on and his [ __ ] two
stars peeing on him that was such a
crazy movie um you know but what I'm
saying it's like you had like when I
learned is like an you know why I
learned it from mostly coming up was in
the Latino community going to the Latino
shows because there was a more community
there
than any other place in terms of like
you know that's what you got paid that's
where like it was like oh we're doing
this show they would take care of you
all you want get some food or like you
you knew where the shows were as I go
you know Rudy Rudy you know Rudy would
be the one like hey come to my show or
whoever it was everybody you know and so
yeah
then we when you get into the club
system you start doing like laughs
actory these kind of places it's
different you know it's different you
know you're it's more like I said it's
like a golf it's like a leaderboard you
know people are watching what people are
doing it's very competitive you know
who's doing what I like I got a pilot oh
you know you won last time I standing
and it was just like oh there goes his
career you know I mean you know it's
like it's just like saying yeah you know
what I never understood about that comic
standing like why didn't they they
should have taken the winner and put
them on a five episode arc on an NBC
show yeah guests are they like what like
like make this person a star put this
person on your network and jam it down
people's throats it's like they had
themselves had contempt for the show you
know it's like NBC themselves felt like
well whoever wins this is like you know
it's like well they won but we don't
really care you know and say why do that
you should have been on Law & Order you
know you should have been like the you
know on a lark on that or they should
have had a sitcom ready to go that they
would just develop but that should have
been the prize the prize should have
been like this person is going to be on
this sitcom it's about this they just
never did that did you say you won a
development deal that worth fifty
thousand yeah and a whole holy deal they
hold you for all years cuz I have
arrived there was opportunities for me
to be on a Fox show but now you you're
being held up by NBC there you go that's
why that's why I was I always like I had
this joke I have about Last Comic
Standing I always wanted to like go I
always wanted to audition again right
because I was this Howard audition I
would go you know I've always wanted to
be on this show because uh I just wanted
the chance to be a film and TV star like
previous contestants you know like um
nobody tell me uh it was um and then
they just keep doing that piss off the
panel yeah there was a foot hold on
there was no no no no they didn't do it
either there was a I just felt like it's
like those kind of thing and then they
set up this like feeling of like if you
won last Comic Standing it's almost like
you cheated or something you know like
oh that's it's the contest person it's
like it's just uh they're not it's like
they're not helpful help me because you
because like but you did it like Rafi
made oh but you already yeah we're doing
it for a long ten years at least yeah
you're already a comic and then it's
this is just like you were showcasing
for an audience to people to be like I
want to go see that guy so that you know
yeah but if you want to be like if you
if it was like if you wanted to be like
on a TV show you want to be in movies
that they didn't they would they weren't
setting it up for that like Rafi was the
one guy that took super advantage of
that he like he tenants day he's still
out there don't you know Turin when he's
got our [ __ ] bus you know what I mean
and that's kind of selling wristbands
bro
he sells wristband yeah I saw this
little wristband for two dollars and he
donate some money to a some kind of
place I don't know where another one
know how many four causes yeah comedians
for rent for rent to be paid but you
know it doesn't talk about that go back
to that dump the thing about how some
community can make a living off of it
and just because we go to one we go to
the when we go to the comedy clubs we
see we still see the same names that
were touring when the comedy boom was
going on yeah and I'm like wow man I
mean this guy he struggling did he say
about money what's going on I mean you
got it's like what do you do like I
don't know what I would do I'll be tired
of going back to the same material I
mean I said I know but not about what
would you do right now like I can't go
get a regular job oh hell no I just like
I'm like this is what I do now but
there's a lot of things you know there's
this there's
cruise ships there's like you know
there's like though it kind of like
lower level comedy clubs of chains like
the comedy zones and Tribble runs and
walkers yeah
there's a funny of those things that
like these people who like they could
come in I mean even if you're even if
it's for a laugh like a considerably
less money than like like you know
$1,500 or like for a weekend but if you
do the door deal yeah or if you pack it
out but if you're doing 30 weekends
that's a pretty good living that's
better than a bus driver or like you
know you're so you there's that level
I'm saying I'm saying making a living
and being a star not the same thing but
you could there's a there's a market out
there for like being a professional
comedian your honor you got your
merchandise you're selling you to get
your your good joke and yet you're yeah
like I'm your hoozy like no one ever
heard of this comedian but we have time
to go check him out go check out his um
his little YouTube on on that show he
does in the morning um with Bob and Tom
Greg Hahn but he's a delirious yeah
nobody's [ __ ] handle area he opened up
for Lewis he killed one of his specials
and my wife Lisa saw him and she also
remember that got away
yeah Daniel Acosta but here's the thing
that guy is an example of somebody
that's like on like the upper echelon of
making like there's people out there
making like 250 300 thousand dollars a
year doing comedy that no one knows who
the hell they are
I mean that's great you know that's
that's a great living you know this you
know if you're out there you have like a
certain rate you built an audience you
know and you're out here doing it that's
great
I mean so that I think that there's a
there's justice expectation that when
you're an entertainment business that
you're supposed to be like when you're
gonna get your own sitcom when you're
going to be in like the this and that
and this and that it's like oh no uh
some people just want it to be a
comedian and they're out there doing it
what if you want to be ro jiggle a
comedian just want to be funny first if
you don't stay to be funny opposed to
just being like you know
he-he-ha-ha and be funny like a post
like you know be funny in front
friends and you know actually didn't go
this is [ __ ] funny Romain is looking
and then after that was my first look
we're doing a sitcom read on television
when you're first I wanted to comment it
be a half an hour like actually be a
comedian I mean I know there was no like
gonna be a [ __ ] be a star in a movie
like any Murphy or neo see a real to
Eddie Murphy money to I was out to get
immersed people in charge delirious oh
yeah I saw the other one place faces I
said back then I remember I'm so funny
like the movies yeah I want to be the
guy that comes like that comes in at a
sitcom three at four episode that
feeling
knocks it out the park and then they put
him in a cooler moving they just get to
tour the rest of the year I know she
talked about how happy my dream my my
thing like that was I wanted to be a lab
tech on CSI that was my thing I wanted
to be like the guy that come in and I'm
like I'm funny you know I mean I might
give like vu yeah I'm giving them the
facts you know and then that's it they
see me then I'm torn I'm too CSI guy all
over the place you know come yeah ten
million people are watching that show so
I thought like that too you know and
then like it as things happen like you
don't you don't realize it at all it
doesn't necessarily work like that you
know because like I said here I've been
on a show for seven seasons and it's not
like you know I'm going someplace and
people like oh the line out the door
they don't even know who you are so you
you realize there's still work to be
done
yeah magic when I was going to do the
shows people go sometime for the people
there don't know I have a podcast they
don't know I've been on superstore yeah
there's no Netflix that's it yeah man
that's why specials are important the
specials are doing it so I hope that
does it for me with my Showtime special
on July 7th on July 7 people I'm called
the ugly truth on Showtime watch it on
your phone on the way to the chalice
festival I want you to Renaissance Fair
just recently so today where do you
filming at I've something that I shoot
something at the Long Beach Laugh
Factory all day but you didn't you won't
you would know because it's like a pet
said oh yeah big blue curtains but it
was like I felt comfortable there
we thought about doing it there too yeah
it was nice and Jamie was very helpful
you know you gave me it was it was all
great I enjoyed the whole process and I
just I had never done
before so I did a half hour but and this
so I just said what do I want to do like
so I just did like I just I was like
here's all the jokes so that some of my
better jokes that I've been doing now
for 10 years developing on the road and
just like doing road I said let me just
do this on this I want to show people
I'm funny this is how I think this is my
sensibility maybe come out and watch me
you know come watch me at the [ __ ]
clubs well today was a special the ugly
truth the ugly truth fool comes out when
July 7th December I run into you like
two three years ago well before I
started with this agency and then you're
like you give me some good advice not
going advice but at least I listened
what you were saying you know you're
saying that um so you were you already
on your own maybe on your fifth season
of that show and and I thought first I
think you thought that I thought you
were headlining all over the place and I
tell you where I'm just telling our
rooms mm I went out to get in my head
Eddie Griffin selling our rooms all over
the place but then you told me oh man
some of the agency won't even pick a
chameleon up no more less you're making
at least $350,000 a year
hey man that's tough could be for just a
[ __ ] with nothing
yeah they don't want to develop it they
don't they don't nobody goes my Lisa
says and if I could agree these Asians
are not going to the club no more yeah
they're not interested but they're not
interested in developing you the ones
that are they're not interested in going
on the ride they wonder they want to
jump on board I feel that way too
no oh god I just got a new phone for
that same thing did i crack it again I
forgot
none of the galaxy eight Jesus ever been
a nightmare I think they almost you
dropped a baby right there
no because it's so expensive these days
oh you know what's funny is I got used
to get these for free day I just program
just fancy like Samsung like White Glove
program they would just give like you
know certain people free but not and I
hadn't bought a phone in like four years
so when I had to buy this I was like god
damn phones are expensive you know these
smartphones but but anyway yeah I know
what you're saying they they don't want
to develop they don't go hey les
I like this guy let's go
album and then we're gonna work with him
you know I don't I don't see that as
much anymore I just see a lot of like
well what do you already have yes
yeah you know how many Twitter photos
you have Eric I only I only have like
like 50 well my last management that how
many how many Twitter photo I have I
still don't have that one
8,000 yeah yeah the whole II care about
you do they want to know work because
they know and you know what I don't
understand either it's like I always
asked I want to know what what did the
club's do before social media you know
what did they do
how do I get people to come to the show
because they have not doing that [ __ ]
anymore
hell no they're just all about like well
can you tweet about if you're a touring
comedian you're at a club every single
week it's like the club you're going to
this week wants you to tweet the club
you're going to next week
wants you to tweet the club you're going
to in two weeks
can you make a video but it's like what
are you doing [ __ ] yeah what are
you doing what a [ __ ] I don't I don't
and the week all these [ __ ] mm loves
and expenses for what I'm here to tweet
I know I know what are you what do you
guys your billboard yeah then it's crazy
I don't know what they're doing
another times man the club doesn't even
treat themselves to the end social media
people that work for a place they always
do it too late even together those are
things comedy bro we do the podcast
today that's the video come out next
Tuesday what the [ __ ] like a new social
media guy bro like I did the video did
today and Wednesday you're gonna show it
on [ __ ] Monday the park and aired on
Friday I hope the views expressed by
Felipe or not reviews so just to play
these or like that's the way it works
with social media know people Atrix like
they're like a man like his son not
understand either the club this is your
city you're in Houston or you know
everybody here like this is your you're
here 365 days a year
this is your city right but you want me
holed up from here who's not from here
and that white and all my followers are
not in your [ __ ] city and you want me
to come and like uh they want the host
to tell the audience to pick up the info
cards that can fill it out and give them
your email I mean what are you doing
what do you do with that it's like it's
so good bizarre
businesses turn on it so now it used to
be you went in the clubs and you build
an audience and build a fanbase
and then you got on TV now you have to
be on TV to get into the clubs yeah
before us way before you would be like
to get a came in for fifteen hundred and
twenty five and yeah yeah yeah the
father you made it and I mean if you
don't do good the first week you
probably won't come now is have to have
not to they're like they have this is a
lower level that they want to pay so
they can pay fifty thousand to the dude
it's got three million followers and our
boys on so whatever would ever show even
though it's not going to be a good show
you know that's why the one-percenters
they're like great comics and famous
that's why they doing what they do
guaran theatres and you know you know
selling that kind of stuff the
Chappelle's Chris Rock's Lewis ek
Bilborough these people they built they
built it up now they're at this like
level where it's like none they're not
going to go to the chuckle hut for you
know you know for whatever however much
money it is no more jukebox bro and
Peoria makes that strip club that
doesn't that's one thing I'm we never
touched on that bro that it's your city
you're here all the time why do I gotta
promote other than saying you were
[ __ ] side you look like Tommy T
they'll hit her truck you have it a
freaking billboard bill all the time
young lady that you can't there is it
1,500 people in this city that you can
get ahold of to come to your shows oh
yeah it's it's like the most bizarre
thing man donate and then they set you
up for failure
and then I'm you bring in the audience
now they want to like they want to they
want everybody email from the audio you
brought hopefully they'll come back to
another show lately but I never had now
I get i'ma get like if they had a good
time I mean once people start going to a
comedy club you become a junkie for it
like they go what cuz it's such a great
time like it's nothing like it cuz you
go you know you you're gonna eat you're
gonna laugh you're gonna drink and like
you're having this to our experience
actually when it's a kick-ass show
it's like it was a great show you just
like oh my god that was the best and
then you start telling your friends you
like and then once you become that
person then your own then you could be
like this now that one guy he wasn't
this funny yeah you start seeing the do
I got
old and then you come back but you still
come back right but it's like they say
they're not getting new customers
because they're not guaranteeing the
product the club itself is bringing in
whoever they're not they're not saying
they're not ensuring that it's a good
show see then you could bring in a
no-name but you're gonna be like you're
gonna tell your crowd this guy's
hilarious trust me trust me and then and
then then you've established a
reputation and then the locals go oh you
got to go to that place because then it
becomes more about the building but
they've made it where it's all about the
comics and if it's all about the comics
then I understand why people are like
why am I gonna go to your club then why
don't I just ran out of you know a bar
why not just run out of our keep the
door you know what you know yes little
one ones kids were lazy
cuz we totally could do that like I
always had always want to do a [ __ ] you
tour like like Susan like that three or
four clubs that don't want a book I've
done that I want to go to I'm picking a
bar a block away from that [ __ ] I did
that I did let him at the Houston bro I
couldn't get in at the houston improv
nothing's not get booked once so I went
to the local comedy club that nobody
wants to do then his martinis club with
the card it was it to be called a comedy
show kids before but now it's called
jokes when something so I said you know
what I'm I rented out the room myself
paid for it right and Lisa was cashier
they had a used to police officer
security guard she was cashier box
office by herself we kept 100% of the
door and I did three shows that night oh
shut up suddenly and then The Improv
heard and then they found out they want
to book me for $2,500 for the whole week
I said wait a minute magic me that one
day you better well step it up buddy now
give me a [ __ ] Dorji or I'm not
coming and then after that bro they got
that's a daughter but I had to prove
myself like let me let me that by put
that word that means that no other
comedian as good as they are as good as
a friendly are they could never threw my
name in there
it doesn't work that way in the more had
some work that way does not work that
way does not work I just like what can I
sell before that oh I'm reading that
book I'm dying up here and Richard Lewis
could get a recommendation from David
Brenner at this comedy club and they'll
believe him he's a good guy but we're in
the guy in Chicago acts like that they
got him Hosseini oh yeah Rick when I
first I first was talking to him long
long time ago before even he was like I
only take recommendations from three
comics in the whole country that's what
he told me who are they I don't even
know nobody you know that loan you never
know who they are you know lucky ducky
Lowe's yeah shucky ducky I'm gonna tell
you about this one Kenya my bag I never
been over the deck hahaha a
recommendation but there was no more
don't do that no more co-signing I'm no
more vouching for anybody the most
awesome to write a baby but this is the
business were in so we have to deal with
whatever it is that's what we have to do
alright what are so fool a regretful
women you're special again it's on July
7th on Showtime and and then that's a
Friday and then remember I'm dying up
here it starts June 4th and there'll be
every Friday at 10 p.m. I'm sorry every
Sunday June 4th Sunday so it's gonna
come on Sunday and then but you could
watch it on the app download the app I
mean Showtime anytime is great it's just
like HBO go or Netflix oh you know it's
a great way to watch Showtime and you
know before you go out what were the
shows shot at at The Comedy Store
no no they built a soundstage in the
Culver City all night it was great for
me cuz I live in Culver City so oh god
I'm glad your bike there yeah man I
could have come from my bed to my
trailer
eight minutes what more could you ask
for done on the trailer when the guy
goes up how did you get in tonight sure
that guy goes cuz I'm [ __ ] you that
guy he's talking to that guy supposed to
be Ali will Prater no no no they all the
characters are fictional
yeah even though the even though real
people exist in our world you know like
like Richard
we had a guy a Richard Pryor on one
episode so it's like that but these are
like it's like a fictional world
fictional comics it's just about their
lives you know and it's like they might
have pieces of somebody like
representing some you know similarity
yeah like Bill Hicks or Robin Williams
or like they have people that are
similar but it's that's just a homage to
those pretty buddy OD on the show you
tell us you don't get to watch master
second are you right
not me I'm the left my character's name
is Ralph King I'm this level-headed like
I write for Sonny and Cher and then you
got it together yeah I got it together
hell yeah I was a Richard Lewis on big
break being in a Sonny and Cher second
show really it again it also days it's
like Sonny and Cher
Merv Griffin Midnight Special and
Tonight Show those are the little ones
those are ones dag so that's another
Tonight Show had 20 million viewers in
one show bro you could you went viral
more than that 41 is more than 20
million do you think single times it was
like like a ridiculous amount that like
you were a household name the next day
those days are done like John Breaux you
could be talking to somebody and they'll
be like they'll be like yeah I just did
it tonight show last night did you see
it it was great and then you go can you
get my salad but thank you for telling
another four hours like that if you're
like damn the Internet is the closest
thing to that gradually the Internet is
the closest thing it's just like keep
something going viral and there's no
rhyme or reason why things go viral
there's no like formula just happens
just happened just happened bro you get
evolved I rule but in closing I'll say
this all you can do is work on your
talent work on your craft keep putting
out content so you're consistent so if
something goes viral you'll be ready
there it is where's the wisdom from Eric
Christmas every day so want to promote
it put um tours
yeah well this weekend I'm going to be
in Mohegan Sun in Connecticut Friday and
Saturday and then just check my website
Eric Griffin calm so I'm going to be in
Tampa in early August would be a side
splitters in Tampa I don't have a lot of
dates books I just switched agencies
yeah you wouldn't know I was CAA now and
so you know I'm just trying to do and
then when I was doing a bunch of filming
so I didn't have I didn't want to cancel
dates so sorry I didn't have anything
booked and then you know going through
this change and then the shows coming
out so just keep looking on my website
and Twitter and all that I'm at aircraft
with the K and you know you'll see me
out there and I come out and say hi
and if you hear me on this podcast make
sure you like walk up to me in tummy hey
what's up fool what's up over jiggle
hell yeah - every Wednesday I'm obsessed
this week with the Arlington improv
Friday - show Saturday - shows Sunday
one show that's a good one also
June 25th the short East LA hopefully
our clock will come out the hospital the
new heart and now ripped and we'll do a
show - 2015 East LA sold out all right
why are so few are bragging about
yourself I have to grow but no one else
does
for me